It's just beautiful, isn't it? It's just mesmerizing.
It's double hel-exciting!
You really can tell, just by looking at it,
how important and amazing it is.
It's pretty much the most complicated molecule
that exists, and potentially the most important one.
It's so complex that we didn't even know
for sure what it looked like
until about 60 years ago.
So multifariously awesome that if you took
all of it from just one of our cells and untangled it,
it would be taller than me.
Now consider that there are probably 50 trillion
cells in my body right now.
Laid end to end, the DNA in those cells would
stretch to the sun.
Not once...
but 600 times!
Mind blown yet?
Hey, you wanna make one? (oh dear god)
Of course you know I'm talking about deoxyribonucleic
acid, known to its friends as DNA.
DNA is what stores our genetic instructions
-- the information that programs all of our
cell's activities.
It's a 6-billion letter code that provides
the assembly instructions for everything that
you are.
And it does the same thing for pretty much
every other living thing.
I'm going to go out on a limb and assume
you're human.
In which case every body cell, or somatic
cell, in you right now, has 46
chromosomes each containing one big DNA molecule.
These chromosomes are packed together tightly
with proteins in the nucleus of the cell.
DNA is a nucleic acid.
And so is its cousin, which we'll also be
talking about, ribonucleic acid, or RNA.
Now if you can make your mind do this, remember
all the way back to episode 3, where we talked
about all the important biological molecules:
carbohydrates, lipids and proteins. That ring
a bell?
Well nucleic acids are the fourth major group
of biological molecules, and for my money
they have the most complicated job of all.
Structurally they're polymers, which means
that each one is made up
of many small, repeating molecular units.
In DNA, these small units are called nucleotides.
Link them together and you have yourself a
polynucleotide.
Now before we actually put these tiny parts
together to build a
DNA molecule like some microscopic piece of
Ikea furniture, let's
first take a look at what makes up each nucleotide.
We're gonna need three things:
1. A five-carbon sugar molecule
2. A phosphate group
3. One of four nitrogen bases
DNA gets the first part its name from our
first ingredient, the sugar
molecule, which is called deoxyribose.
But all the really significant stuff, the
genetic coding that makes you YOU,
is found among the four nitrogenous bases:
adenine (A), thymine (T), cytosine (C) and
guanine (G).
It's important to note that in living organisms,
DNA doesn't exist
as a single polynucleotide molecule, but rather
a pair of molecules that
are held tightly together.
They're like an intertwined, microscopic,
double spiral staircase.
Basically, just a ladder, but twisted. The
famous Double Helix.
And like any good structure, we have to have
a main support.
In DNA, the sugars and phosphates bond together
to form twin backbones.
These sugar-phosphate bonds run down each
side of the helix but, chemically, in opposite directions.
In other words, if you look at each of the
sugar-phosphate backbones, you'll see that
one appears upside-down in relation to the
other.
One strand begins at the top with the first
phosphate connected to the sugar molecule's
5th carbon and then ending where the next
phosphate would go, with a free end at the
sugar's 3rd carbon.
This creates a pattern called 5' (5 prime)
and 3' (3 prime).
I've always thought of the deoxyribose with
an arrow, with the oxygen as the point.
It always 'points' from from 3' to 5'.
Now on the other strand, it's exactly the
opposite.
It begins up top with a free end at the sugar's
3rd carbon and the phosphates connect to the
sugars' fifth carbons all the way down.
And it ends at the bottom with a phosphate.
And you've probably figured this out already,
but this is called the 3' to 5' direction.
Now it is time to make ourselves one of these
famous double helices.
These two long chains are linked by the nitrogenous
bases via relatively weak hydrogen bonds.
But they can't be just any pair of nitrogenous
bases.
Thankfully, when it comes to figuring out
what part goes where, all you have to do is
remember is that if one nucleotide has an
adenine base (A),
only thymine (T) can be its counterpart (A-T).
Likewise, guanine (G) can only bond with cytosine
[C] (G-C).
These bonded nitrogenous bases are called
base pairs.
The G-C pairing has three hydrogen bonds,
making it slightly stronger than the A-T base-pair,
which only has two bonds.
It's the order of these four nucleobases
or the Base Sequence that allows your DNA
to create you.
So, AGGTCCATG means something completely different
as a base sequence than, say, TTCAGTCG.
Human chromosome 1, the largest of all our
chromosomes, contains a single molecule of
DNA with 247 million base pairs.
If you printed all of the letters of chromosome
1 into a book, it would be about 200,000 pages
And each of your somatic cells has 46 DNA
molecules tightly packed into its nucleus
-- that's one for each of your chromosomes.
Put all 46 molecules together and we're
talking about roughly 6 billion base pairs
.... In every cell!
This is the longest book I've ever read.
It's about 1,000 pages long.
If we were to fill it with our DNA sequence,
we'd need about 10,000 of them to fit our
entire genome.
POP QUIZ!!!
Let's test your skills using a very short
strand of DNA.
I'll give you one base sequence -- you
give me the base sequence that appears on
the other strand.
Okay, here goes:
5' -- AGGTCCG -- 3'
And... time's up.
The answer is:
3' -- TCCAGGC -- 5'
See how that works? It's not super complicated.
Since each nitrogenous base only has one counterpart,
you can use one base sequence to predict what
its matching sequence is going to look like.
So could I make the same base sequence with
a strand of that "other" nucleic acid,
RNA?
No, you could not.
RNA is certainly similar to its cousin DNA
-- it has a sugar-phosphate backbone with
nucleotide bases attached to it.
But there are THREE major differences:
1. RNA is a single-stranded molecule -- no
double helix here.
2. The sugar in RNA is ribose, which has one
more oxygen atom than deoxyribose, hence the
whole starting with an R instead of a D thing.
3. Also, RNA does not contain thymine. Its
fourth nucleotide is the base uracil, so it
bonds with adenine instead.
RNA is super important in the production of
our proteins, and you'll see later that
it has a crucial role in the replication of
DNA.
But first...
Biolo-graphies!
Yes, plural this week!
Because when you start talking about something
as multitudinously awesome and elegant as
DNA, you have to wonder:
WHO figured all of this out?
And how big was their brain?
Well unsurprisingly, it actually took a lot
of different brains, in a lot of different
countries
and nearly a hundred years of thinking to
do it.
The names you usually hear when someone asks
who discovered DNA are James Watson and Francis
Crick.
But that's BUNK. They did not discover DNA.
Nor did they discover that DNA contained genetic
information.
DNA itself was discovered in 1869 by a Swiss
biologist named Friedrich Miescher.
His deal was studying white blood cells.
And he got those white blood cells in the
most horrible way you could possibly imagine,
from collecting used bandages from a nearby
hospital.
It's for science he did it!
He bathed the cells in warm alcohol to remove
the lipids,
then he set enzymes loose on them to digest
the proteins.
What was left, after all that, was snotty
gray stuff that he knew must be some new kind
of biological substance.
He called it nuclein, but was later to become
known as nucleic acid.
But Miescher didn't know what its role was
or what it looked like.
One of those scientists who helped figure
that out was Rosalind Franklin, a young biophysicist
in London nearly a hundred years later.
Using a technique called x-ray diffraction,
Franklin may have been the first to confirm
the helical structure of DNA.
She also figured out that the sugar-phosphate
backbone existed on the outside of its structure.
So why is Rosalind Franklin not exactly a
household name? Two reasons:
1. Unlike Watson & Crick, Franklin was happy
to share data with her rivals. It was Franklin
who informed Watson & Crick that an earlier
theory
of a triple-helix structure was not possible,
and in doing so she indicated that DNA may
indeed be a double helix.
Later, her images confirming the helical structure
of DNA were shown to Watson without her knowledge.
Her work was eventually published in Nature,
but not until after two papers by Watson and
Crick had already appeared in which the duo
only hinted at her contribution.
2. Even worse than that, the Nobel Prize Committee
couldn't even consider her for the prize
that they awarded in 1962 because of how dead
she was.
The really tragic thing is that it's totally
possible that her scientific work may have
led to her early death of ovarian cancer at
the age of 37.
At the time, the X-Ray diffraction technology
that she was using to photograph DNA required
dangerous amounts of radiation exposure, and
Franklin rarely took precautions to protect herself.
Nobel Prizes cannot be awarded posthumously.
Many believe she would have shared Watson
and Crick's medal if she had been alive
to receive it.
Now that we know the basics of DNA's structure,
we need to understand how it copies itself,
because cells are constantly dividing, and
that requires a complete copy of all of that
DNA information.
It turns out that our cells are extremely
good at this -- our cells can create the
equivalent 10,000 copies of this book in just
a few hours.
That, my friends, is called replication.
Every cell in your body has a copy of the
same DNA. It started from an original copy
and it will copy itself trillions of times
over the course of a lifetime, each time using
half of the original DNA strand as a template
to build a new molecule.
So, how is a teenage boy like the enzyme Helicase?
They both want to unzip your genes. (Hank why)
Helicase is marvelous, unwinding the double
helix at breakneck speeds, slicing open those
loose hydrogen bonds between the base pairs.
The point where the splitting starts is known
as the replication fork, has a top strand,
called the leading strand, or the good guy
strand as I call it
and another bottom strand called the lagging
strand, which I like to call the scumbag strand,
because it is a pain in the butt to deal with.
These unwound sections can now be used as
templates to create two complementary DNA strands.
But remember the two strands go in opposite
directions, in terms of their chemical structure,
which means making a new DNA strand for the
leading strand is going to be much easier
for the lagging strand.
For the leading, good guy, strand an enzyme
called DNA polymerase just adds matching nucleotides
onto the main stem all the way down the molecule.
But before it can do that it needs a section
of nucleotides that fill in the section that's
just been unzipped.
Starting at the very beginning of the DNA
molecule, DNA polymerase needs a bit of a
primer, just a little thing for it to hook
on to so that it can start building the new
DNA chain.
And for that little primer, we can thank the
enzyme RNA primase.
The leading strand only needs this RNA primer
once at the very beginning.
Then DNA polymerase is all, "I got this"
and just follows the unzipping, adding new
nucleotides to the new chain continuously,
all the way down the molecule.
Copying the lagging, or scumbag strand, is,
well, he's a freaking scumbag.
This is because DNA polymerase can only copy
strands in the 5' -- 3' direction,
and the lagging strand is 3' -- 5',
so DNA polymerase can only add new nucleotides
to the free, 3' end of a primer.
So maybe the real scumbag here is the DNA
polymerase.
Since the lagging strand runs in the opposite
direction, it has to be copied as a series
of segments.
Here that awesome little enzyme RNA Primase
does its thing again, laying down an occasional
short little RNA primer that gives the DNA
Polymerase a starting point to then work backwards
along the strand.
This is done in a ton of individual segments,
each 1,000 to 2,000 base pairs long and each
starting with an RNA primer, called Okazaki
fragments after the couple of married scientists
who discovered this step of the process in
the 1960s.
And thank goodness they were married so we
can just call them Okazaki fragments instead
of Okazaki-someone's-someone fragments.
These allow the strands to be synthesized
in short bursts.
Then another kind of DNA Polymerase has to
go back over and replace all those RNA Primers
and THEN all of the little fragments get joined
up by a final enzyme called DNA Ligase. And
that is why I say
the lagging strand is such a scumbag!
DNA replication gets it wrong about one in
every 10 billion nucleotides.
But don't think your body doesn't have
an app for that!
It turns out DNA polymerases can also proofread,
in a sense,
removing nucleotides from the end of a strand
when they discover a mismatched base.
Because the last thing we want is an A when
it would have been a G!
Considering how tightly packed DNA is into
each one of our cells, it's honestly amazing
that more mistakes don't happen.
Remember, we're talking about millions of
miles worth of this stuff inside us.
And this, my friends, is why scientists are
not exaggerating when they call DNA the most
celebrated molecule of all time.
So, you might as well look this episode over
a couple of times and appreciate it for yourself.
And in the mean time, gear up for next week,
when we're going to talk about how those
six feet of kick-ass actually makes you, you.
Thank you to all the people here at Crash
Course who helped make this episode awesome.
You can click on any of these things to go
back to that section of the video.
If you have any questions, please, of course,
ask them in the comments or on Facebook or Twitter.